[MUSICAL SOUND EFFECT]
SPEAKER 1: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Google Cambridge.
We're very pleased to
have, today, Susan Maycock
and Charles Sullivan of the
Cambridge Historical Commission
with us.
They'll be talking about their
book, "Building Old Cambridge."
Old Cambridge is the area
around Harvard Square.
And it's especially interesting
for a bunch of reasons.
One of them is, of course,
Harvard, and all the activity
that goes with Harvard, and some
of the special buildings there.
Now, we all know about the
Georgian, and the Victorian,
and the neo-Georgian
buildings at Harvard.
But all-- Harvard also has
the only Le Corbusier building
in North America.
It has two buildings by the
great architect HH Richardson
and so on, so interesting area.
But beyond that, there are
other interesting things
in the Harvard Square area.
Brattle Street, an old street,
has been rich for a long time,
from before the Revolution.
It was known as Tory
Row, so there were
many Tories on Brattle Street.
I'm always curious to
know, what happened
to them after the revolution,
why were they there
in the first place, why were
they in Cambridge rather
than Boston, things like this.
So the architectural history
and the history of the region,
of the area, tells
us a lot about
the social, economic,
and political history
of the area as well.
And I believe Charlie's also
going to be talking, today,
about some of the development
of the Kendall Square, which,
when I first knew
it many years ago,
was a bombed-out flat
area, and is no longer.
So I think this will be a
really interesting talk.
So Susan, I think we'll be
introducing, and then Charlie.
Oh, by the way, this is
a book I got, I think,
40 years ago about
Old Cambridge.
And now, with the additional
research that's been done,
we see that they've
made it a lot thicker.
So a lot of research
has been done, a lot
of interesting background.
And I look forward to it.
SUSAN MAYCOCK: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Actually, we
started out thinking
we would just kind of
update that red one that's
been out of print for
years, and years, and years,
and should come back in, because
it's a really interesting area.
And once we started
looking at it,
once we started working on it
and realized how much more we
had learned since 1972,
when that was published,
it just sort of wrote
itself and ended up
with 1,100 photographs and maps.
And what you get
is a hefty volume.
So I thought that I would talk
to you a little bit about who
the Historical Commission
is and what it does.
And then Charlie's going
to introduce the book
and talk some about
Kendall Square as well.
So the Cambridge
Historical Commission
is actually part of
the city government.
And it's a department that deals
with historic preservation.
And with that, it
works to preserve
buildings, and sometimes,
whole neighborhoods.
And it also helps people
understand the context
of their buildings and--
oh, are you-- can you hear me?
SPEAKER 1: Yep.
SUSAN MAYCOCK: --the
context of their buildings
and how Cambridge came to
look the way it looks today.
So the Commission protects over
3,000 buildings in Cambridge.
But we have a file,
an informational file,
on every single building,
all 13,000 of them.
And this includes
information on the history,
maybe on the
architects, the builder,
who built it in the first
place, who it was built for.
And we then have
thousands of photographs
of individual buildings,
but also of areas, and maps,
and city directories.
So all of this is
open to the public.
And we have researchers come in,
and we help them with whatever.
If you wanted to know if
all of these people who
live in Cambridge want to
know about their building
or their house, give
us a call or come in.
And we'll walk you
through it individually
and see what we can find.
And sometimes it's great.
We have newspaper articles from
the time the buildings were
built, et cetera.
Main part of the
Commission's mission
has always been
outreach, which we
do through helping researchers.
We also make house calls.
We go out.
We talk to help people with
their technical issues.
We also consult on
paint colors to make
them appropriate for the
exterior of their house
depending on the history and
the style of their house, which
is mandatory in the
historic district,
but is just informational in
any other part of Cambridge.
But it's made a huge
difference over--
we started doing it in the--
during the bicentennial.
And over that
time, Cambridge has
gone from being gray, gray
and white, yellow and white,
and white to many of the
colors that you see today.
And we also publish books
on the various neighborhoods
and buildings of Cambridge.
And this is our newest one,
"Building Old Cambridge."
And it's also our biggest
one, as you can see,
and our most well-illustrated.
But the title, "Building
Old Cambridge,"
sometimes needs a
little explanation.
Because some people
think it's building
Ye Olde Cambridge or
old Cambridge buildings,
buildings that are old.
But it actually, as
Stavros said, is--
it's centered on the area
around Harvard Square that
was the original
settlement in 1630.
So it became known
as Old Cambridge
to differentiate it from the
newer areas such as Cambridge
Port and East Cambridge that
were developed in the 1800s.
And so "Old
Cambridge," as a name,
shows up on the map on
the cover of the book.
And it shows up on
some early maps.
But these other areas didn't
develop until almost 200 years
after Old Cambridge was
established and developing.
So Charles will give
you the history of that.
But now you know where you are.
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
OK, thanks, Susan.
What people have been
telling you is true,
that Cambridge was founded
in 1630 several miles
up the Charles River from--
from Boston Harbor.
It was intended to be the
capital of Massachusetts.
It was the only town laid out
on a grid plan in New England
until New Haven was
founded a few years later.
The intersecting streets of
Kennedy, Dunster, Holyoke, Mass
Ave., Mount Auburn Street,
Winthrop Street, South Street
are the original
grid plan of 1630.
The legislature,
in 1634, decided
that Boston was a better
choice and moved the capital
to Boston.
And in 1636, they gave
Cambridge Harvard University,
or Harvard College as it was
at the time, favoring New Town,
as the village was then
called, over Salem, which
was the other town
in competition
for the first college
in the colonies--
or in the Northeast.
So this map shows the
original settlement
at what's now Harvard Square,
Boston on its peninsula,
surrounded by
water on all sides,
connected to the mainland only
by a narrow street, Washington
Street, that would
flood at high tides.
And Kendall Square, you'll see
represented by this purple star
throughout the presentation
to give you some orientation.
Kendall Square was,
for 100 years--
150 years-- at least, was not
a place where anyone would go
or even could go, and
certainly not at high tide.
Because most of it would
have been underwater.
So in this period, and until
1793, there are only two ways
to get to Boston,
none of them direct.
The road to Boston crossed
by the Harvard Stadium
went down through Brookline
Village, Dudley Square, and up
Washington Street
eight miles by road.
Or you could go four
miles out to what's,
today, Sullivan Square,
down into Charlestown,
and take a ferry
into Boston, and pay
for the privilege, of course.
So Cambridge was isolated.
The college liked it that way,
kept the undergraduates out
of trouble.
And Cambridge remained
a very small village
for the first couple of hundred
years of its settlement.
This is the first
view of Cambridge
made by a French intelligence
agent who came down
from Quebec in the 1660s.
Produced this map 20 years
later that shows the meeting
house and the college.
These are two Harvard buildings,
this one and this one.
And then, the village
around it have
called it a town of 80
houses and one university.
AUDIENCE: The meeting
house, would that
be First Church Cambridge?
CHARLES SULLIVAN: This
would be 80 houses in--
AUDIENCE: No, the meeting house.
The meeting house?
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
The meeting house--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Was First
Church Cambridge?
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
Yes, First Parish.
AUDIENCE: First Parish.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: First Parish.
And there's a whole
ecclesiastical history
about the difference
between the first parish
and the first church.
It's not a happy story.
But this is the first
church of the first parish--
or the first meeting
house of the first parish.
So by the Revolution--
you know, this is, what,
135 years after settlement--
the village at Harvard Square
was really still very small
and grouped around the
university, or the--
Harvard Yard, as it became.
This is Massachusetts Hall.
That's the fourth meeting
house on the corner,
where Lehman Hall is today.
This-- the kiosk is right
there in that triangle.
This is the old burying ground
at the corner of Garden Street.
There's the bridge
over the Charles.
The stadium's over here.
This is-- you can--
perhaps you can make this out.
This is a hill surrounded-- or
not surrounded, but bordered--
by salt marshes along the river.
The curve of Brattle
Street and Elliot Street
is described by a creek that
rose in Harvard Yard, rose--
went through Harvard Square,
around the foot of the hill,
and out here by Elliott House.
So the village is nestled
on top of this hill.
Winthrop Square, the little
open space on Kennedy Street,
was the town marketplace and
has always been a public space.
So the landscape at the
time of the Revolution
was characterized--
was an agricultural landscape.
But a lot of it was
occupied by estates,
by the Loyalist families who had
settled plantations in the West
Indies, and in Barbados,
Jamaica, Antigua, and the rest,
and found the
climate unsupportable
for raising families, began
to establish second homes
in Rhode Island, and on the
Mystic River in Massachusetts,
and on the Charles
River around the 1750s.
And so by 1775,
a good proportion
of the town of what's
today Cambridge
was occupied by these estates.
These were wealthy
families who were
politically loyal to
the English government.
They were slave owners.
Many of them had planta--
sugar plantations
in the West Indies, brought
their slaves from there.
These were all sort of
gentlemen's plantations.
They weren't really
agricultural enterprises.
But they did occupy a
large amount of territory.
There's Kendall Square,
off on the edge of town.
The brown divisions
are lot lines.
These are property divisions.
And the characteristic
of this area,
these long, long, narrow
lots represented--
the only thing of value that
was generated in this area
was salt marsh hay,
which was extremely
valuable for agricultural use.
You could mulch with it.
The seeds wouldn't
germinate in fresh water.
Cows could bed in it.
You know, cows would eat it.
It was extremely val--
the most valuable agricultural
product in Cambridge.
So these lights were constantly
being subdivided among heirs.
And you might have a
lot 8 or 10 feet wide
running for several hundred
feet into the marshes
down to the mudflats.
Otherwise, Kendall Square
was basically worthless.
So the Loyalist
estates all had houses,
of which this was the
grandest, on Brattle Street.
This is now the Longfellow
National Historic Site.
George Washington slept
here during the early days
of the Revolution.
And common people lived
in the village in houses
like this, on Kennedy Street
at the corner of South Street.
The landscape at the
time of the Revolution
is really almost
completely open.
Most of the natural forest
cover had long since
disappeared, been cut over.
The agriculture here was
mostly grazing and pasturing.
The soil wasn't very
productive, so there
weren't many crops that
were raised, although it
was good soil for fruit trees.
So this is a view looking
from over West Cambridge.
This is Brattle Street
running down into the village.
This is Sparks Street.
And this is the Charles
River and the Great Bridge,
what's now the Anderson
Bridge, by the Harvard Stadium,
Dana Hill in the background on
the horizon beyond the village.
So the Charles River
is tidal until 1909.
It's the easiest
way to get around.
But of course, it floods.
The banks are shallow.
These views, by the
way, are of a model
that we made at the time
of the bicentennial that
were based on the best
available research at the time.
So we still think
they're pretty reliable.
The tide, it's
about a half tide.
And so you can make out
the channel of the river.
And you can make
out the mudflats.
This is where the
business school is
today, Harvard Business School.
And then, these
are salt marshes.
This is the edge
of a salt marsh.
So at spring tides, about
once a month, all of this area
would flood right up
to about that line.
So this is a neighborhood
called The Marsh--
still called The
Marsh-- in Cambridge.
It was settled in the
1850s by Irish immigrants.
Kerry Corner down here,
beyond the Harvard houses,
was the lower marsh.
And the marshes covered
large parts of the town.
So the person who took advantage
of all of this open space
around the village
was Francis Dana,
who was America's first to
Ambassador to St. Petersburg,
came back and became the chief
justice of Massachusetts.
He lived in a house on
Dana Hill over here.
This is a view taken from
about the site of Weidner
Library looking east on--
this is Harvard Street.
Massachusetts Avenue
is going off there.
The Inn at Harvard
would be about here.
Francis Dana lived--
or was a patriot,
lived on the scale
of the Loyalists
who lost their estates
after the Revolution
in this house which was right
about there, on Massachusetts
Avenue where Dana
Street comes in.
There's a bluff that falls off--
if you're going towards Harvard
Square, falls off on your left.
There are views all around.
And at that time, in
that open landscape,
Dana could see
across Boston, could
see ships coming
into Boston Harbor,
and had an open view of
all of this landscape east
of the village, which, by
the time of the Revolution
had only three farms.
There was one at Leachmere's
Point in East Cambridge,
there was another one
up here, and another one
right about behind city hall,
Dana's house, dated a couple
of years after the Revolution.
So Kendall Square, you can see,
in this fairly detailed chart,
is really at the
edge of nowhere.
There is the channel
of the Charles River
at low tide with soundings.
Would bring you up--
you could navigate about
as far as Boston Common
or the public garden.
But you needed at least a
half tide or a full tide
to get up to past Harvard
Square, which was often done.
These were the flats.
And these were the
salt marshes that
made East Cambridge an
island at high tides.
So a lot of this,
a lot of what's
now dry ground in Cambridge,
originated as tidelands.
So what Dana did was to
get investors together
to build the first
bridge direct to Boston.
This is the West
Boston Bridge of 1793
on the line of the
Longfellow Bridge
where the subway crosses.
That's the state
house on Beacon Hill.
We're looking from Cambridge,
from Kendall Square,
into Boston.
So very quickly, within
about 35 years, what had--
a territory that
had only three farms
suddenly has two new villages.
This is a map of 1830.
So all of these streets,
all of these buildings
in this area east
of Harvard Square
have all developed
in 35 years' time.
What the West Boston
Bridge did was
to open up a desire
line that extended up
into the middle of Vermont.
Middle and southern Vermont,
western Massachusetts,
southern New Hampshire, all of
that, our agricultural produce
wanted to reach
the Boston Market.
And all of it had formerly
had to be transported
through Charlestown or the long
way around that I showed you.
Now, all of a sudden,
they could save five miles
of travel on dirt roads by
accessing the West Boston
Bridge through Kendall Square.
So the bridge was actually about
3/4 of a mile across and 3/4
of a mile of causeway
across the mudflats
down to Lafayette
Square, and then
promoted the construction
of River Street,
and Western Avenue, and those
bridges of Massachusetts Avenue
up to the village
of Harvard Street.
Broadway was
actually an extension
of the Concord Turnpike.
So Concord Avenue, and
Broadway, and Cambridge
were built as a toll road
going out to Concord.
Hampshire Street, it was
the Middlesex Turnpike.
So it was named Hampshire
Street because it
led to New Hampshire, to
Tewksbury, on the Merrimack
River, where it connected
with one of the New Hampshire
turnpikes.
And then in 1809,
a second bridge
was built across
from East Cambridge.
And that led to another--
to a grid plant settlement
at East Cambridge,
and another street, Cambridge
Street, and other improvements.
And these real estate people
and bridge proprietors
were constantly competing to
shortcut each other's routes
to open up land for development,
to attract activity.
And it was a period
of enormous turmoil.
It was just an insane free for
all for real estate developers.
Because after 35 years,
you have a village
at Cambridgeport, which
is settled primarily
by migrants from
northern New England
from the maritimes who are
dealing with highway traffic.
They're running taverns
and scales and workshops
serving the traffic into
Kendall Square, into Boston.
East Cambridge is founded
as an industrial suburb
around the glassworks.
So Lafayette Square,
which is the intersection
of Main Street and Mass Avenue,
had the first meeting house
in Cambridgeport.
That's where some of you may
remember the Shell station that
used to be there and then
that's now part of a park.
That's Main Street
going off here,
Massachusetts avenue coming
from Harvard Square there.
These were taverns and
warehouses and stores
serving people on the
highways to Boston.
East Cambridge is industrial.
The New England glassworks
is founded there
in the early days
of the century.
Workers were imported
from Germany and Scotland
to work in the glass factories.
And the town grew up around
them and the Middlesex county
courthouse.
Whereas the old
village, by this time,
was becoming known
as Old Cambridge--
is a simple, a quiet,
more or less settled
place that's been there
for two centuries already.
So it has a sense
of its heritage.
It has Harvard, the
world's soon to become--
and even then-- the world's
greatest university, right?
And so Old Cambridge had
an attitude toward it
that caused resentment in East
Cambridge and Cambridgeport,
where people were new, where
they had to go to town meeting
and ask for funds for schools
and roads and services
that the Old Cambridge taxpayers
were not eager to give.
So in the 1840s, folks in Old
Cambridge attempted to secede
and set themselves off
as a separate town.
And divide this
town at Lee Street,
and cut loose Cambridgeport
and East Cambridge.
And then Old Cambridge then
would become a separate town
with North Cambridge
as kind of a suburb.
So by this time, this is another
25 years after the 1830 map,
you can see that the grid
plant in East Cambridge
is filling out.
The streets in Cambridgeport
are filling out pretty
satisfactorily.
Not much is happening
at Kendall Square,
but I'll come back
to that in a minute.
So the town, in the
1850s, began to see itself
as a potential suburb of Boston.
Boston was becoming overcrowded.
The Irish were settling
in the North End,
driving out the Yankees, who
were looking for new places
to live.
Cambridge was an
obvious prospect.
The tolls on the bridges
disappeared in 1854.
Two men had this vision--
Gardner Greene Hubbard
and Estes Howe.
Howe is a medical doctor
who gave it up and became
a real estate investor.
Gardner Hubbard
was an attorney who
is best known because his
daughter married Alexander
Graham Bell.
She was deaf.
He was her teacher.
Hubbard was the lawyer who set
up the original Bell Telephone
companies and had the idea of--
you used to have to rent
your telephone equipment
from AT&T. Pay a monthly
rent for that handset
with the dial, which was the
brilliant idea that Gillette
used to sell you razors
and razor blades,
and made AT&T the
powerhouse that it was.
So Hubbard started
out in real estate.
And to serve his
real estate ventures,
he established a whole series of
important urban infrastructure
ventures.
The first one was the
Harvard branch railroad
that came down from
the Fitchburg division
in Somerville, at a station
where the Harvard Law School is
facing Cambridge Common.
It only lasted five years.
It couldn't attract
enough passengers.
It was the first railroad
abandoned in Massachusetts.
In 1852, he and Howe established
the Cambridge Gas Company.
Gas was produced at that time
by heating coal in a retort,
driving off the gas,
and then that leaves you
with coke as a byproduct.
But the coal would be
captured in a gas holder.
This is a conical
structure with a roof
that barely shows up here.
But that encloses
a steel tank, which
is like an upside down
cup and a water seal.
Gas is produced by heating coal.
It is pumped into that
container, the weight of which
provides the pressure to drive
the gas out into the mains,
under the streets,
into people's homes,
where it was mostly
used for eliminating
and for street lights
in this early period.
This is at the foot of Ash
Street, where the Memorial
Drive apartments are now.
So they also founded
the Cambridge Waterworks
as a private business
in 1852, to take water
from a fresh pond.
They built a reservoir
on Reservoir Hill
with a standpipe for
additional pressure,
laid pipes under the
streets and the city
actually took this over in 1865,
and it's now the current water
department.
And then they founded
the Cambridge railroad,
which was the first horse
railroad, the first street
railroad, the second in the
US after one in New Orleans,
to run from Boden Square in
Boston at Government Center,
out Main Street and Mass
Avenue to Harvard Square,
and out beyond that
to Mount Auburn.
Mount Auburn Cemetery--
which sounds strange,
but Mount Auburn was like
the amusement park at the end
of the streetcar line.
It was a place where people
in Boston, in the thousands,
would go on weekends
to enjoy the landscape.
And so by the 1860s,
Harvard Square
is becoming a real center for
the western part of Cambridge,
but also for the
western suburbs.
All the streetcar lines
that came in from Watertown,
from Newton, from
Waltham, from Arlington
all funneled into
Harvard Square,
where people would change to
take the streetcar into Boston.
So it became a transfer point
and got an economic importance
that it had never
had in the first 200
years of its existence.
Harvard Square is
also characterized
by a lot of buildings
and services
that were intended to support
students at the University.
These buildings-- one of them
was built by the University
as a dormitory for
graduate students.
These were early
private dormitories.
Harvard never intended,
and did not provide,
accommodations for
all of its students.
By the end of the 19th
century, only seniors
were guaranteed dormitory rooms,
and they lived in the yard.
Everybody else, including
14-year-old freshmen
would have to find
accommodations in the town.
Either at boarding
houses, or for the people
who had well-to-do parents,
in private dormitories
that were built expressly for
this purpose, where students
would get together and live
in, essentially, apartments
without cooking facilities.
Everybody ate in the town, in
restaurants and lunch rooms
in the village in
Harvard Square.
Harvard came late to providing
dining hall services,
and that was a much,
much later development.
And in fact, Harvard
undergraduates
didn't have to live
in Harvard dorms.
And Harvard could not provide
Harvard accommodations
until about 1929, when the river
houses were finally opened.
So the rest of Cambridge, of
Old Cambridge at this point,
was becoming a suburb.
This is Mass Avenue looking
north towards Porter Square--
in this period was one
of the most prestigious
residential streets
in the Boston area.
All of these large
mansions going up and down
the street on both sides.
There was no commercial activity
here until about World War I.
At the end of Mass
Avenue is Porter Square.
This is what
suburban Cambridge--
this best represents
suburban Cambridge.
There's the railroad station
where the subway headhouse
is now in Harvard Square.
There's a train in the cut.
There's a horse car on
Massachusetts Avenue
at the corner of Upland Road.
These churches actually
existed, and so
did this little house, which
now faces Porter Square,
faces the Porter
Square bookstore.
This engraving,
this lithograph was
done as a real estate promotion
for the property associated
with this house, which was known
as the Pine Island cottage.
There's a pine tree.
There's the island.
[LAUGHTER]
We thought this-- when
we first saw this,
we thought this
is just a cartoon.
This is a joke.
But in fact, this little
pond and this little island
show up on a map.
And there it is.
So this is how
Cambridge was developing
in the 19th century as a
middle class suburb of Boston.
So now we're going to
go to Kendall Square.
This is Kendall Square, or
the Cambridgeport shoreline
in 1847.
The bridge-- there's
the West Boston Bridge.
That's the bridge
head, about where--
well, now the dry
land is about here,
and the streets
intersecting here.
So this area
initially had a burst
of activity after the Bridge was
built. A group of entrepreneurs
had the vision that if they
dug canals through the marshes,
that they could attract
traffic coming out
of the Middlesex Canal.
The Middlesex Canal
came out in the Charles
up around Sullivan Square.
Canal boats could
cross the Charles
into the north end of Boston.
And they thought, well, why not
have canal boats come up here
into Kendall Square, where
they can unload their traffic
cargoes, granite and wood
and lumber and firewood,
and transshipped them to coastal
schooners for trade elsewhere.
So folks built the Broad Canal,
which exists now to about here,
but once went all the way
back to Portland Street
and up behind, all the way
through East Cambridge.
There's a cross
canal, there's a dock.
This is Broadway.
This is Harvard Street,
which once connected to Main,
and a dock and a South
Canal, a cross canal,
and we are right about there.
This is Dock Street.
That was the dock.
A stub of Dock Street exists
next to the fire station,
the Firehouse Hotel
across the street.
It was called Dock Street
for obvious reasons.
So when you came across the
river from Boston in the 1850s,
this is the replacement for the
original West Boston Bridge,
but it's on the same
location with a drawbridge
in the middle.
That's Kendall Square
in the background.
If that factory right
there is this one,
if you came across
at low tide, you
had the kind of obnoxious
experience of a mudflat
at low tide, where all the
sewage of all of Kendall Square
and of all the surrounding
towns was pumped directly
into the Charles River.
It became an enormous
public health hazard.
As the tide went out, the sewage
collects on the mud flats,
dries out in the sun.
It's blown around in the clouds
of dust in the westerly winds,
and was a major
impediment to people
living anywhere near
the Charles River
until an interceptor sewer
was built in the 1890s.
So moving on into
Kendall Square,
that's Broadway and Main Street.
Boston is behind us.
And the hotel is over here,
and then your office building,
this building, is in
the middle of this block
somewhere back here.
So by this time, from
say, the 1840s on,
this is actually a
residential neighborhood.
There was an elementary
school down here,
a collection of houses.
People lived here,
worked in the factories
nearby, or commuted into Boston.
The Broad Canal, like
everything on the Charles,
emptied out at low tide.
It was served by
coastal schooners.
This slide's not very
clear, but that's
the stern of a two-masted
schooner that's
tied up at a wharf here.
Two-masted schooners
were the semi-trailers
of the 19th century.
They carried any
kind of bulk cargo
anywhere you had more than maybe
six feet of water at high tide.
They had to be flat-bottomed,
because as the tide went out,
they'd rest on the mud.
But they were
capacious and cheap,
and functioned in
coastal commerce
until the 1920s in New England.
So the Broad Canal runs almost
a mile up into Cambridgeport.
The industries here at this
time in the late 19th century
were smokestack industries.
George Blake started out
developing steam-powered pumps
for emptying out clay pits.
And in World War
I, the company--
it was said that every
naval ship that was launched
had between 3 and
400 pumps from Blake
performing different
functions on the ship.
This became a national supplier
of steam pumps and machinery.
Part of that complex,
this part right
here, the former
brass foundry, still
exists on the corner of
Binney and 3rd Street.
Just down Binney Street, Alden
Speare was a chemical company.
These brick buildings,
this brick building
was owned by Standard
Oil, was a warehouse.
Had a railroad siding behind it.
Those brick buildings
are now part
of Biogen. They've
been adapted or reused
as part of the Biogen complex.
Further up Binney is
Boston Woven Hose & Rubber.
Rubber was a major
industry in this area.
There were at least two rubber
factories, American Rubber
on the east side
of Binney Street,
and then Boston Woven Hose
was a major national supplier
of hoses.
This complex still exists.
The Kendall Square Cinema
is right back there
where the Boston and Albany
Freight House used to be.
All of these buildings,
almost all of these buildings
still exist, except for
this one and this one.
And if you look around,
at least on the perimeter
of Kendall Square, you can
see these layers of history--
that part of which,
I have to say,
we've managed to
protect on purpose.
Because we want to preserve
these memories of when
Cambridge was a place where
people made things, where it
was a smokestack town that
was, in the early 20th century,
being compared to Detroit as an
emerging industrial powerhouse.
And you can think of
where Detroit went
and where we'd
gone, I think we got
the better part of the bargain.
So by 1910, the Longfellow
Bridge has been completed here.
The subway's not in place yet,
but that's Kendall Square.
Well, Kendall Square
is actually there.
But this is the
industrial area around it.
East Cambridge was off up here.
This building still exists.
That's the Athenaeum
Press Building.
It has the statue of Athena that
you can see from the Red Line
as you cross.
Athenaeum Press was a textbook
publisher for the most part.
But they, too, had their
smokestack aspects.
They received their
paper and fuel,
and presumably shipped out
their school books, by rail.
All of this area north
of the Broad Canal
was laced with
railroad sitings that
served the various
industries until the 1960s.
Then on the other side of
Main Street, where the Charles
River used to come
right up to Main Street
and where MIT is
today, all of that
had to be filled and enclosed
and the tides kept out.
So this is looking from
the Longfellow Bridge
down to the Harvard Bridge
where Massachusetts Avenue is
crossing.
MIT is down somewhere
in the far distance.
These are our schooners that
are bringing blocks of granite
from Cape Ann and
laying them on the mud,
actually on pilings
driven into the mud.
So this is the seawall,
the current seawall,
that comes from the Longfellow
Bridge, curves, around
and goes down past MIT and past
the Bridge, almost to the BU
bridge.
Then steam power
dredges suck sand
out of the remaining
basin of the Charles River
across the seawall to
fill in all of this area
to make dry ground.
So that process works like this.
This is 1889.
There's been a little
bit of filling down here.
The original shoreline is back
almost to Brookline Street,
down here towards the BU Bridge.
But by Mass Avenue, not
much has been filled.
There's a natural point here.
The Harvard Bridge on
Mass Ave. has been built,
or is being built at this time.
And all of this area is mudflat.
Kendall Square is up at the top.
And the next photograph is
taken from this perspective
going across open water.
So we're standing
on this bulkhead.
That's Main Street.
This is the Firehouse Hotel.
There is the city's coal wharf.
That's where the city
got its fuel for schools
and municipal buildings.
And your building is
right in the middle
of that complex of factories and
three deckers on the other side
of Main Street.
So this area, where you
used to be able to--
Google would probably
do this for you
now, give you a
landing with a boat
that you could take
out at lunchtime--
except it's a little bit further
of a walk than it used to be.
So this is probably
tide's part way down.
High tide-- you know, it's a
nine foot tidal range here.
So high tide is just below,
and you can see that mark, just
below the edge of the bulkhead.
But you can sail for a
good few hours a day.
So once the seawall was
built, Longfellow Bridge
is at the bottom.
And there's Memorial Drive,
MIT in the background.
You're about there.
The firehouse is here.
It creates a whole
swath of new land--
buildings like 238 Main,
with a clock tower that's
designed not so you can
tell time around here,
but so people in Boston
will see it on the horizon,
and say, oh, that's
where Kendall Square is.
Let's put our
factory over there.
But by the 1950s,
this is a area where
the industry is in decline.
After World War II, a lot of
firms closed up or moved south.
And areas, a lot
of Kendall Square,
broadly, Kendall Square,
became parking lots for people
to take driving in, taking
the subway into Boston.
So there's the clock tower.
Your building's off to the left.
This is Third
Street coming down.
This is the only building in the
picture that's still standing.
All of these other
buildings were taken down
in the urban renewal period.
This is the modern
version of the gas holder
that I showed you from the
1870s that was up on Ash Street.
Because the gasworks
moved down here,
coal was brought into the
Broad Canal heated and so on.
Also a lot of oil was
brought in on barges,
transhipped in the Broad Canal.
So there's the clock
tower building.
The earlier views looking across
here at these gas holders.
There's the Broad
Canal, which currently
stops right about here, as
it originally extended up
into the neighborhood.
You guys are about here.
And fuel oil deliveries--
after the Texas
pipelines reached
New England in about 1952,
they stopped making coal gas.
That's why we talk
about natural gas,
because natural gas is coming
by pipeline from Texas.
What they had
previously was coal gas.
But they all called it gas.
Then natural gas came in as a
distinctly different product.
The fuel oil deliveries lasted
until about the mid-1980s,
and since then, the Broad Canal
hasn't had any industrial use.
Other landmarks were the
demise of Lever Brothers,
the soap manufacturers
had their major US factory
and headquarters
here on Broadway,
between Broadway
and Main Street.
That was taken down in 1958,
replaced by Tech Square.
The first chapter in the modern
history of Kendall Square
is the construction
of Tech Square
by MIT and a private
real estate developer.
Then NASA came along.
NASA was developing its
space program in the 1960s.
They were going to
build a Space Center
in Houston, where it is today.
They wanted an electronics
research center
that would be close to MIT.
They were looking for
3,200 acres close to MIT.
[LAUGHTER]
They settled for 14
acres in Kendall Square.
That was industrial
land that was going
to be cleared for this purpose.
So this is looking from--
there's Boston Logan Hose.
This is Hampshire
Street and Broadway.
That's the end, the very end
of the Broad Canal going off
towards the Charles River.
So this area was all designated
as an urban renewal area.
There were 3,000
people working here,
so it was a major
gamble by the city
to clear out those
3,000 jobs on the hope
that 20th century jobs
would replace them.
The initial design
for the NASA Center
was going to be like
this, with three towers,
for this electronics
research center
and a commercial development
along Main Street.
What happened was that about
half of one tower was built.
That's the building that's
over here now at Volpe.
And part of this building
was built. The rest of it
was never built.
So this is what the city
came up with to replace
all of those parking lots, a
development that you are now
a part of.
And Kendall Square
then continued.
And for the old
guys in the room,
there's the F&T Delicatessen
and the F&T Diner,
while the subway is being--
[LAUGHTER] I knew
that'd get you.
The subway station's
being extended.
So these buildings are
now being preserved.
So I've got to finish up
quickly with Harvard Square.
So Harvard Square joins the 20th
century, in the 20th century.
And it gets a
subway station, gets
buildings that are
familiar today.
In the 1970s, it becomes a
different kind of a capitol.
Some of you recognize that.
And now you can see this
view recalls the model view.
There is Massachusetts Avenue.
That's where the
meeting house was,
and the cemetery down here.
So what have I not talked about?
This is a seven
pound, 13 ounce book.
So there's a lot more.
There's neighborhood history.
There's Harvard University.
There's printing and publishing.
This is from the
Library of Congress.
That's the Riverside press
seal in the ceiling of one
of their buildings.
Residential
architecture-- you get
Susan to come back and talk
about that, about business
and commercial architecture.
About river transportation,
the schooners
that went up to wharfs
in Harvard Square
and even into
Watertown until 1900.
Mass transportation--
the subway and streetcar
yards that dominated parts of
Harvard Square until the 1960s.
And social history, not least--
Longfellow and his wife.
She's holding Charlie Longfellow
by his neck, so that he--
because you couldn't move.
Charlie was squirmy.
George Washington Lewis and
his wife Penelope Farwell.
The Goodies, who
were cleaning ladies
at Harvard in the 19th century,
and the African-American
waiters at Memorial Hall.
So all of these folks are
represented in the book,
and that's my last word.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, Charlie.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: Come on.
Did I answer every single
question you might have?
I know I'm comprehensive.
OK, yes?
AUDIENCE: So some
number of years ago--
some number of years ago
while I was between jobs,
I was hanging out at
the Registry of Deeds
doing basically title
search on my property just
to figure out what
its history was.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: That means--
AUDIENCE: And I got--
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
--you're hard core.
AUDIENCE: And I got back as
far as the mid to late 1800s,
where I learned that it was
part of the almshouse lands.
And I wasn't able to get
any further back than that.
And I was wondering if
you had any comments
about the almshouse and
what was there before.
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
Well, there were
three different almshouses.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: This would have
been on Prospect Street.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: On Prospect.
Prospect Street?
AUDIENCE: 66.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: OK,
well, here's my card.
AUDIENCE: Almshouse land, I
think between Austin Street
and Harvard Street.
Or maybe [INAUDIBLE] a little.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: OK.
That's a new one.
Here's my card.
Give us a call.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CHARLES SULLIVAN: We'll talk.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's
kind of interesting
how Cambridge sort of went from
vast expanses of farmland slash
nothing into house
upon house upon house.
I'm wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit on how
sort of the ownership
worked for these marshes
and even the river parts
that got filled in.
Was there someone who
just was extraordinarily
lucky who owned all that
land and got to sell it off?
Or how does ownership work when
they create land like that?
CHARLES SULLIVAN: Well, if
you remember the slide that
had all the loyalist estates
on it, that one showed you
areas where real
estate development was
relatively measured and
carefully organized.
So that was represented
capital to those land owners,
and they would carefully lay
out streets and sell off lots
and try to do it in sequence.
Other areas where
there were farms,
it was divided up and pretty
much sold off at random.
There's this whole process.
There's no central planning
of streets in Cambridge
until the 20th century.
So the streets would be laid
out by the property developers.
They would try to
work with each other.
Typically they'd sell
lots, two or three lots
at a time, at most,
to a carpenter who
would build the houses on spec,
live in one until he sold it,
and then buy another
two or three lots.
So it's a pretty
disorganized organic process.
It's not centrally
located, centrally planned.
Nothing like, you know,
Levittown comes to mind.
But you know nothing like
organized suburban development
except Coolidge
Hill and Larchwood
in West Cambridge
in the 20th century
were small, planned suburbs.
Everything else
is kind of random.
AUDIENCE: How
early would you say
was all of the land privately
owned in some respects?
CHARLES SULLIVAN: Privately
owned as opposed to?
AUDIENCE: As opposed to land no
one has settled on yet, right?
Was that back in the
1600s, basically?
CHARLES SULLIVAN:
Land was granted out.
Some of it was owned in common.
It was, well, let's say--
in 1630, it was all owned in
common by the Massachusetts Bay
Company.
And so it was
divided into towns.
Towns would organize
as parishes, actually,
and as proprietors.
In Cambridge, there
were the proprietors
of common lands, group of
citizens that were authorized
to divide public land and give
it out to existing property
owners.
So that was complete by 1750.
After that, there was almost
no more public land left.
So every scrap was
privately owned.
AUDIENCE: So, for
example, the mudflats
that became MIT,
who were they owned
by before they were drained?
CHARLES SULLIVAN: Well.
The flats-- in Massachusetts,
you can own tidelands out
to the low tide line.
And so they didn't
have much value,
but you could get title to them.
And an individual did.
A guy named Charles Davenport--
had a factory further
down on Main Street--
thought he saw a lot of
potential in the tidelands.
And he's the one that organized
a company to build the seawall
and fill in those flats.
But he was buying them for
pennies in the 1860s and '70s
and assembling all of that
tideland so that then he
could do a major development.
Where MIT is, it was supposed
to be a neighborhood that
would mirror Boston's Back Bay.
That's a whole other talk.
But you know, Back Bay--
same thing.
Seawall-- filled in behind the
sea wall, straight streets laid
out, lots sold on a
consistent, planned basis.
They were trying to do the
same thing in Cambridge,
but didn't work.
And MIT came along
and scooped it up.
Thank goodness.
AUDIENCE: And south
of east Cambridge,
it was bought up by a
development company.
And they planned it all out.
So it was a bigger area.
And you got more
regular streets,
but then they sold it off.
SPEAKER 1: Well, let's
thank our speakers again.
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLES SULLIVAN: Thank you.
Thanks a lot.